petit pot pour grand sourire c'est le
nom de cette opération de solidarité
organisée par sept photographes à
travers la france dont l'yvelinois
l'élan courtois frédéric grah bonsoir et
bienvenue sur ce plateau ce n'est pas la
première fois que vous venez nous parler
de cette opération
vous l'aviez déjà mené une séance photo
professionnelle c'est ce que vous
proposez pour les enfants à tous ceux
qui donneront le petit pot des couches
des repas bébé du lait 1er ou 2ème âge
où les produits d'hygiène donc pour les
tout-petits ces dons en nature qui sont
ensuite donnés au secours populaire donc
du département des yvelines
on imagine comme succès a été au rendez
vous sur les précédentes éditions oui
comment ça fonctionne et justement
qu'elles sont un petit peu les les
chiffres ben donc déjà ça un terme de
d'enfants photographiés pour moi dans
mon studio on est en à tourner aux
alentours des 70 à 90 en fin d'année
dernière ce qui représente à peu près 45
familles les virements d'être généreux
dont il ya eu énormément de dons puisque
je rappelle que du coup ils ne payent
pas la c1 c'est chez moi puisqu'il amène
des dents et voilà ça s'est super bien
passé tout le monde était content et
notamment le secours populaire donc avec
mes six amis photographes on a décidé de
renouveler sa cette année à nouveau on
peut citer par exemple en quelques
chiffres 2008 sans couche 800 repas
reversés au secours populaire en échange
de cette séance photo c'est l'opération
vous organisez je disais vous êtes 7 à
participer à ça c'est ça tu as mis sept
copains ouais c'est comme ça que
l'opération est né oui en fait parce
qu'on est réellement amis dans la vie
donc il ya six filles et deux garçons
mon collègue d'année à brest sophie dans
le nord sophie dans le sud dans les
bouches du rhône
là il faut les citer tous parce que
sinon après ça va faire des jaloux
hélène dans le var et marjorie en savoie
et ma collègue marie louise dans les
yvelines
à conflans sainte honorine et pour ceux
qui se sont rendus sur le site internet
sur le facebook notamment que vous avez
mis en place autour de l'opération vous
pouvez consulter le petit clip qui a été
réalisé qu'on aperçoit justement on vous
voit en plein effort la raf qu'un prix
coline pour venir nous parler de cette
opération
1 l'offre est limitée tout de même bon
de préciser parce que vous êtes un peu
victime de votre succès c'est 70
familles en fête et 70 familles
pour réaliser des photos qui ne
connaissent pas le studio voilà on a
rallongé la durée un petit peu des
opérations par rapport à l'année
dernière parce qu'en fait j'ai eu
tellement de demandes l'année dernière
que j'ai donc j'ai dû dire beaucoup de
personnes non et pour essayer justement
de répondre au maximum aux personnes
j'ai décidé cette année de 2,2 d'ouvrir
le studio en fait aux personnes qui sont
jamais venus pour en profiter et comme
ça d'une part ça me fait connaître aussi
faut être honnête et
et puis d'autre part ça permet aussi de
renouveler les gens pour pour qu'ils
offrent des dons au secours populaire
puisque l'objectif est double bien
évidemment faire une opération de
solidarité puis faire connaître votre
activité
allez jamais caché produit aujourd'hui
bien évidemment la première opération le
premier but vraiment de tous les sept si
on le fait c'est vraiment pour aider les
enfants parce que date nous tous ceux
qui nous font gagner notre vie il faut
être honnête sur les enfants parce qu'on
photographie énormément d'enfants au
quotidien quoi donc on voulait que ce
soit tournée vers les enfants et puis
oui après il faut être honnête et sait
aussi se faire connaître et que nos
studios soient connues le plus dur en
public voilà mais ça ça a fonctionné par
exemple par rapport à l'an dernier à la
suite de cette opération ça fait rire
nos clients l'opéra pour moi l'opération
ça m'a fait gagner ma vie cela n'est
d'accord donc il me reste un vrai bond
de fréquentation ensuite après grâce à
cette opération
c'est là dans le cadre de cette
opération c'est une vraie prestation
professionnelle
oui peut préciser que vous offrons va
voir quelques-uns des clichés d'ailleurs
que vous réalisez des précédentes années
pendant que pendant qu'on discute sur ce
plateau véritablement comment ça se
déroule une séance photo
les séances que vous allez offrir alors
en fait c'est exactement comme si les
gens ni payées d'accord donc la séance
dure à peu près une heure d'accord donc
qu'ils arrivent donc déjà part mais je
leur envoie mes conseils en terme de
tenue vestimentaire pour que les gens
soient accordés entre eux et caetera et
et puis voilà puis après les gens et les
enfants ils sont très rapidement naturel
vous savez on les fait courir on les
fait sauter c'est pas tienne toi droit
souris se terminer ça donc
ils amènent leur petit univers leurs
jouets leur doudou fais vraiment pour
qu'ils se sentent à l'aise et pour qu'on
retrouve des images qui leur ressemble
voilà et donc le coût pour les familles
qui vont participer on le rappelle sur
l'opération que vous organisez qui a
débuté le 5 janvier qui va se dérouler
jusqu'à quand d'ailleurs alors ça débute
le 5 janvier les prix du jusqu'au 31
janvier
c'est surtout une fois vous inscrire
tout à fait il ya un règlement tout ça
qu'il faut lire le site internet va
s'afficher aussi comme ça ces gens
viendront s'y référer et donc ensuite et
ensuite il y à un petit concours
organisé sur facebook
d'accord ou là en fait il ya des
catégories et les gens les internautes
qui votent pour la plus jolie photo et
chaque photo de catégories d'achats
catégorie gagne un agrandissement 50 50
des emplois gagnés
donc en plus en donnant on est
doublement doublement gagnant est ce que
l'objectif aussi à terme parce que ça
marche plutôt bien c'est de l'élargir
cette opération alors à d'autres
collègues avoué puis éventuellement
d'autres organismes aussi parce que là
c'est pour le secours populaire
alors je vais être honnête avez-vous on
y est très très très longuement réfléchi
cette année avec mes six acolytes
l'histoire est née de l'amitié d'abord
et c'est on a préféré rester à sept en
fait dans le sens où l'organisation
c'est très lourd
et entre nous on ya des échanges qui
sont parfois un peu virulent et c'est
très délicat de rester entre amis dans
ces cas voilà exactement pour ça après
exactement et et c'est tellement dur ne
serait ce que le petit le petit extrait
du clip vidéo vous avez rien que pour
mettre ça en place en est que cette
c'est un travail de titan quoi et ça
paraît pas ça paraît rien ça dure une
minute mais franchement pour on est tous
disséminés dans la france entière donc
pour les images détournées ont essayé de
tourner ensemble et c'est super dur pour
faire quelque chose de cohérent droit et
le choix du secours populaire
d'autres organismes éventuellement alors
là aussi or c'est le partenariat
là aussi on y réfléchit on essaie d'y
est-ce qu'on tourne tous les ans et ce
qu'on essaie de faire quelque chose de
pérenne
on a choisi cette solution la seconde la
pérennité l'année dernière c'est parce
que ben il y avait déjà dans ma rue qui
travaillent seront populaires
bénévolement et je voulais moi leur dire
merci quelque part et l'ac thann en a
discuté et on tendrait justement avec le
secours populaire au niveau national de
d'essayer de faire quelque chose de
pérenne et donc on va peut-être pas
changé l'association tout de suite voilà
et ça fonctionnait très bien également
pour vos différents collègues à travers
la france
oui de d'un point de vue général on
était tous super content tout le monde a
joué le jeu et honnêtement dans tous les
studios il ya eu des dons et c'est
vraiment d'une manière conséquente quoi
et sur votre studio encore il reste
encore des places et les gens à l'issue
de cet entretien veulent participer
bien sûr alors il reste encore des
places je vais pas vous cacher je ne
reste pas beaucoup je vous le dit tout à
l'heure j'ai énormément de 25 croyable
et donc bien sûr qu'ils aient nakhla
préconise le règlement bain par rapport
aux à certaines contraintes ne peuvent
pas mais il reste des places il ya pas
de soucis peuvent les gens qu'on peut
encore s'inscrire
mais voilà dans quinze jours si vous
voulez faire un don vous prenez donc
contact avec le studio du photographe
frédéric grah qui est à l encours vous
pouvez ensuite avoir tout les touts les
toutes les informations il faudra faire
un don secours populaire et puis en
échange cette séance photo et la
publication d'une des photos d'un des
clichés pour un petit concours
oui via facebook voilà c'est ça merci
frederig ar d'être venu nous parler de
cette jolie opération qui fonctionne
plutôt bien du sport pour finir à
présent cette édition du 7 8
comme chaque année traditionnellement
est organisé un concours une compétition
amicale de futsal proposé par l'étoile
sportive de guyancourt anthony rech
revient sur cet événement
aux abords d'un terrain de futsal le
maillot de lionel messi est toujours
omniprésent
les jeunes joueurs saint quentinois rêve
d'imiter le quadruple ballon d'or dans
ses dribbles unique
le futsal n'est pas aussi abordable
techniquement que son grand frère
d'extérieur next-gen mettre les crampons
et puis les caleçons petit donc ça un
petit peu plus difficile donc ses
meilleurs c'est un peu plus dur ou
picasso petit émirat est réduit il faut
bien se placer sur le terrain comme
l'idée qu'ils sont mélodie on apprend
on connaît plus de personnes et j'aime
bien cette ambiance à deux équipes de
cinq s'affrontent le gardien doit
dégager le ballon à la main et les
touches s'effectue au pied contrairement
au football en plein air le ballon ne
décolle quasiment jamais du sol le jeu
est fait de passes courtes et de gestes
techniques comme le célèbre passements
de jambes
le futsal réclame plus d'endurance les
distances étant plus courte qu'à
l'extérieur le temps de réaction doit
être élevée pour que les enchaînements
soit assez rapide de petits espaces fait
pour les manieurs de ballon les joueurs
techniques s'en sortiront très très bien
en salle parce que techniquement aussi
sont à l'aise à l'extérieur 1 re en
salle ça doit être pareil et pour les
grands dribbleurs c'est l'occasion de
pouvoir se régaler dans ce genre de
compétition quelle que soit la taille du
terrain le plaisir de jouer ensemble
domine pendant 12 minutes de match
cette édition du 7 8 va bientôt
s'achever je vous propose à présent de
voir leurs rappels des titres les
principaux sujets que nous avons
développé ce soir et que vous pourrez
également retrouver sur notre site
internet dès demain matin
magny les hameaux au coeur de toutes les
attentions politique pour ses premiers
voeux le nouveau maire bertrand guillon
a été soutenue par un ministre
socialiste benoît hamon également par la
présidente du parti socialiste
départementale sandrine grand gaube le
travail le dimanche le dossier et
juridique il est aussi social et humain
nous nous sommes rendus dans une
enseigne de bricolage c'était dimanche
dernier pour savoir ce qu'en pensent ses
clients et salariés ils sont plutôt
unanimes le travail le dimanche quand il
est volontaire c'est un plus pour que
les satellites envoie les bonnes
informations il dispose de réflecteurs
des réflecteurs fabriqué à la main par
astrium aux mureaux du médine yvelines
de très haute technologie
et puis le portrait de dalila cette
couturière d'intérieur et tapissière
également vous avez sans doute déjà vu
son travail au château de breteuil à
choisel elle s'est occupée des rideaux
mais aussi à des tapisseries magny les
hameaux donc nous nous y rendons à dès à
présent retour sur la cérémonie de voeux
toute particulière cette année c'était
la première du nouveau maire bertrand ou
lyon et pourquoi tout le monde s'est
pressé dans cette commune voici la
réponse première cérémonie de voeux en
ce 7 janvier pour le nouveau maire de
magny les hameaux et du beau monde pour
écouter le discours du socialiste
bertrand où ils ont élu en septembre
dernier après le départ de jacques
lolliot en poste depuis 1995 ministre
député maire de sa couleur politique
étaient présents pour ce baptême du feu
à nouveau maire nouvelle activité
curiosité peut-être curiosité mais aussi
lucidité si les socialistes se montrent
eux aussi mobilisés c'est sans doute car
magny les hameaux attise les convoitises
l'ump espère bien conquérir la ville aux
municipales de mars 2014
valérie pécresse était d'ailleurs
présente comme de nombreux élus
yvelinois de droite qui entendent faire
basculer l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines qui a toujours était
détenu par
gauche on peut aussi gagner des communes
sur la droite dans cette agglo il ya il
encourt en particulier sur lesquelles on
va mettre beaucoup de moyens donc manie
n'est pas un cas particulier pour nous
c'est simplement une ville a conforté
c'était à la fois un soutien amical
et puis politique aussi pour lui dire qu
il peut évidemment compter sur nous tous
les municipales au coeur des discussions
de couloir lors de cette soirée est la
rumeur d'une candidature de benoît hamon
sur la liste de guy malandain à trappes
qui se fait de plus en plus insistantes
je n'ai pas encore discuté à guy
malandain si on me le propose on en
discutera mais pour l'instant
n'a pas encore parlé l'enseigne vers
jean vers un dépôt de bilan imminent les
syndicats ont rencontré aujourd'hui le
principal actionnaire butler capital
partners c'était donc ce mardi 8 janvier
et les syndicats qui a annoncé à l'issue
de la réunion que le principal
actionnaire est prêt à déposer le bilan
dès demain mercredi 1200 emplois qui
sont menacés dans les 26 magasins en
france dont ceux de les emplois de
montigny le bretonneux au centre
commercial
skywest je vous propose à présent
d'écouter ce micro trottoir que nous
avons réalisé que pensez vous des
difficultés actuellement traversées par
vers jean voici vos réponses
je trouve que c'est dommage parce que
j'y vais j'achète des disques de temps
en temps c'est dommage bah écoute et j'y
vais j'y vais pas déjà mais bon c'est
vrai que c'est triste quoi pour les
salariés
c'est c'est pas je pense qu'ils auraient
pu se moderniser et faire quelque chose
pour perdurer puisque c'est dommage
puisque il ya beaucoup de choses dans
magasin est géré assez souvent pour les
dvd et les livres ça va encore créer du
chômage et ça c'est dramatique
voilà ça se comprend en quelque sorte de
nos jours de virtuel prend le dessus
c'est malheureux c'est malheureux de la
perdante pas que ce serait enfin là ce
que génère cette ce plan c'est par
rapport au plan humain c'est vrai que
c'est malheureux voilà pour ces quelques
réactions alors que l'enseigne vers jean
devrait déposer le bilan demain 26
magasins je vous le rappelle entre 1000
et 1200 emplois à travers la france dont
les emplois de montigny le bretonneux
c'est le seul magasin des yvelines que
possède la chaîne c'est la fin du à 7,8
pour aujourd'hui rendez vous demain
mercredi dès 18 heures en direct pour
une nouvelle édition au programme le
club de guyancourt en football qui se
prépare à recevoir celui d'auxerre pour
la coupe gambardella
et puis la mise en place d'une halte
répit pour les accompagnants des
personnes atteintes d'alzheimer c'est
une initiative de la croix rouge nous
reviendrons aussi bien évidemment sur
l'ouverture des soldes et vous devriez
être nombreux excellente soirée à demain
sur tv fil 78 n'oubliez pas les réseaux
sociaux twitter en particulier hashtag
le 7 8 pour commenter nos programmes